no matter where they live the elves sure
know how to decorate so what's so
important about the elvish realm of
linden and amazon's the rings of power
now that the lord of the rings the rings
of power is officially out audiences are
seeing several middle-earth regions
through a time traveling lens including
linden the elvish nation technically
shows up in the lord of the rings for a
short sequence at the very end of the
story when frodo and bilbo hop on a ship
at the grey havens but by that point the
area is a skeletal remnant to the
powerful fairy kingdom that exists there
during the rings of power narrative
which is set during the second age of
middle-earth history during that story
the elf capital linden is a powerhouse
linden is one of the last major
strongholds of elven glory before the
elder children of iluvatar fade away
replaced by the young up-and-coming race
of men the time has come
for the dominion of men
here's a quick breakdown of the elven
kingdom and the crucial part it plays in
bridging the gap between the epic elder
days and the lord of the rings story
that fans know so well
technically speaking linden doesn't
exist as a unified and structured
kingdom until the second age begins
however elves live for a very long time
and quite a few live in the area before
it becomes a proper kingdom the
silmarillion explains that the region is
initially called oscerian the green
elves dwell there living secluded lives
it reads they were clad in green in
spring and summer and the sounds of
their singing could be heard even across
the waters of galeon wherefore the
noldor named that country lindem the
land of music i hear it said that
when you cross over you hear a song
one whose memory we all carry
when the first age ends the land to the
west of linden sinks into a catastrophic
world breaking event called the war of
wrath in the process linden becomes the
farthest western point on the middle
earth map
linden is a major source of elvish power
during the second age there are other
areas where elvis strongholds pop up but
none of them rival linden its leader is
a fellow named gilgalad he's the fourth
and last high king of a famous group of
elves called the noldor his herald is a
character that fans of the lord of the
rings are quite familiar with a
half-elven dude named elrond when linden
is founded elrond is eons away from his
future as a wise and mighty counselor
and the leader of rivendell at this
point he's a very young elf burdened by
incredible ancestry trying to find his
way in the world a couple of other
important elves spent time in linden
with these two key leaders the first is
galadriel who may have lived there
before she left leading elves east
toward the misty mountains
in the rings of power storyline
galadriel is more integrated into linden
serving when the show starts as a
commander of its northern armies the
final health we can't fail to mention
here is kyrdan a famous shipbuilder who
spends his days helping his world-weary
people leave middle-earth to set sail
for the blessed realm away in the west
the first rise of sauron defines the
second age of middle-earth history in
the third age that follows sauron
re-emerges hunts for his ring and is
ultimately toppled by a hobbit a scrappy
king in exile and a few other pretty
important folks
keep breathing
watch the key
breathe
in the second age though sauron is just
starting to settle into his role the
first thing he does is dress up on a
handsome physical form and call himself
anatar lord of gifts he tries to dupe
the elves into thinking he's a good guy
that can help them this is how he ends
up making a bunch of rings of power with
some of the elves before that happens
the folks in linden try to stop him
simorillian explains only to linden he
did not come for gilgalad and elrond
doubted him in his fair seaming and
though they knew not who and truth he
was they would not admit him to that
land gilgalad and elrond continued to
doubt sauron in disguise until matters
finally come to a head about halfway
through the second age
eventually the secret gets out that
anatar is sauron after he you know makes
the one ring and tries to control him
directly and stuff when that happens war
erupts and sauron goes on the offensive
gogolad lends linden's armies under
elrond's command to resist sauron's
forces they fail which leads to elrond
retreating and founding rivendale it's a
setback but linden isn't destroyed on
the contrary it turns into one of the
key areas of middle earth that sauron
can't conquer many elves use linden's
havens during this time to hightail it
out of middle earth entirely but
gilgalad holds together enough of his
people to overcome the dark lord over
the rest of the second age the fate of
middle earth swings back and forth
linden continues to play a key role and
gilgalad receives help from the men of
numenor the protracted centuries-long
drama ends temporarily at least when
gilgalad and ellendale form the last
alliance of elves and men the group
gathers and heads down south where both
leaders are killed and ellen dill's son
isildur cuts the one ring from sauron's
hand
after sauron's first fall the third age
begins linden still exists as an area
where elves dwell but its power is
greatly diminished so while the area
continues to be relevant as an elfish
gateway from middle-earth to the blessed
realm otherwise its political prowess is
irrelevant its king is dead its new
leader kierdan while a wise and
masterful shipbuilder isn't a high king
about to gather and lead the elves to
battle it's worth noting though that
some of the wizards come through his
havens and he even gives one of them an
elven ring to help him with his mission
gandalf
[Music]
even though there isn't much else going
on the area continues to be distinctly
important and very elvish the hobbits
who settle down on the nearby shire
halfway through the age have stories of
the area so in the end linden slowly
fades into a forgotten elvish realm lost
on the edge of the middle-earth story
but it doesn't change the fact that it
plays a prominent role in the second age
an age that the rings of power series is
about to explore in detail
[Music]